[Music]
as I mentioned in the opening monologue
tonight CNN fired their contributor mark
Lamont Hill for his outrageous comments
about Israel but it's only the latest
example of insanity at the so-called
facts first network is sabor they're
hysterical and saying crazy biased
coverage is this president trying to
impersonate Hugo Chavez rest up tie up
Earl on Vladimir Putin what a great case
officer Vladimir Putin is he knows how
to handle an asset and that's what he's
doing with the president when do we see
almost a shadow government come out and
say we cannot side with the government
why is President Trump showing sympathy
for white nationalists and other hate
groups what does that tell you in
America that one that in one generation
called you what does that tell you Don
we can truly say his words have
absolutely emboldened white supremacist
16 tweets today to start the new year
some of them deeply disturbing these are
the messages from a person who is not
well from a leader who is not fit for
office he's president snowflake okay
everything he said oh they're mean to me
and they don't like me and I just don't
understand that it is not just there
this was a white lash this was a white
lash against a changing country it was a
white lash against a black president in
part alright now we now bring in joe
contra media reporter for the hill and i
guess my favorite and all that is van
jones or maybe dr. humpty dumpty giving
his diagnosis yeah I don't think we
should ever really be giving with
somebody as somebody who's married to a
doctor you probably don't want to play a
doctor on TV when you're basically you
know doing a diagnosis from afar yeah
that that's never a good look look
obviously Marc Lamont Hill Sean had to
be fired in this situation you mentioned
it before free Palestine from the river
to the sea that's right out of a Hamas
grip that calls for the annihilation of
Israel no question about it I'm not big
on firings and in these sort of
situations but this was unavoidable but
here's the thing CNN has somewhere to
around 40 to 50 contributors underneath
their umbrella
so firing mark Lamont Hill isn't that
hard of a thing to do because you have
three four dozen other people you could
just plug in there the other bigger
names that you showed during that
montage people that are on the air more
people that are anchors on that network
or host shows they're a lot harder to
fire in the situation I'm not calling
from them to be fired because look if we
were to fire every single person that
called the president a racist or fascist
or question his mental health on
national television
90% of this industry working at what
Martha the holidays yeah I am arguing
it's literally every almost every second
of every minute of every hour of every
day stormy stormy stormy Russia in
Russia that's all that's all
Michael avenatti TV it's not there's is
no they say they're reporters I'm a
talk-show host
I do some objective reporting
investigative reporting do a lot of
opinion I'm the whole newspaper but they
say their news they're dishonest well
then that's the thing right I mean if we
were to talk about say a Don Lemon for
example he's called an anchor on the
network he's somebody who gives opinions
it gets confusing after a while same
thing with Anderson Cooper or Chris
Cuomo their anchors therefore they
should be on there asking questions and
gathering information or Jim Acosta at
White House briefings asking questions
gathering information instead all these
people share their innermost feelings on
certain topics there are emotions they
debate in certain situations and that's
that's not what the job is and I think
that's where mistrust comes to within
people watching at home and watching the
media they don't know who the anchors
are from the opinion people from the
pundits anymore and then they Europe
they hear any of these people when they
hear a side being given then they don't
know what to conclude from that because
it sounds like it's you're trying to
draw the the viewer to a conclusion
instead of letting them draw their own
conclusions and I think that's a big
problem in our industry right now no
question listen I admit I'm a talk show
host we sometimes do straight news we
sometimes do opinion sometimes do
investigative reporting but we tell you
we do it all they say they do one thing
they know